After arriving home from a quick
ski trip to Aspen with the kids,
I decided to
put together a batch of fermented muffin butter
so I could send them off to school the next morning
with a healthy,
nutrient dense breakfast.
My goal was to roll out of bed
and basically throw the muffins in the oven,
so I did the bulk of the leg work the night before.
My top priority is always feeding my children
foods that will make them thrive.
And that's why the only wheat I bake with is ironcorn.
It's the most ancient form of wheat
and has never been hybridized,
which means that it's a pure and original grain.
In fact, we thrived on it for thousands of years.
It's much higher in antioxidants,
protein, and keratinoids,
especially when compared to modern wheat.
And the coolest part is
it doesn't upset your stomach.
These muffins are so wholesome,
low and unrefined
coconut sugar.
I only used five tablespoons for the entire batch.
And they even use up sourdough discard
that you probably have in the back of the fridge.